day at 8 00 pm eastern time
and that's a look at the schedule here
on c-span
this is book notes c-span 60-minute
discussion with the authors of public
policy historical and political works
for the next hour you'll see behind the
titles and gain insight into the authors
as people and the experiences which
shape their lives
this week our guest is lewis lapham
editor of harper's magazine he joins us
to discuss his recent book the wish for
kings democracy at bay
[Music]
h lapham author of the wish for kings
democracy at bay you have a chapter
called versailles on the potomac
what's it about
it's about the splendor of washington
that has
been uh the magnificence of its marble
of its pretensions of its uh
bureaucratic vastness so it has become
like a palace of versailles i mean and
it is a court society a world unto
itself sometimes called inside the
beltway
and it's grown and multiplied since the
end of the second world war so that the
expense of of government the number of
functionaries of people who serve
government and it's in its many
facets i mean i think there's something
like now a hundred thousand lawyers
lobbyists
work on various degrees of
regulation and
the congress the staff of the congress
has multiplied to 35 000 and it's
it's this sense of a vast
versailles
court
a hall of mirrors in which
the various servants of government
flatter one another or blame one another
strike poses
issue bills
make announcements
stage pageants of one kind or another
that's the
view of it in that chapter you have a
story in here about robert mossbacker
the former secretary of commerce i do
when mossbacker first
came to
he was appointed by bush and he came
from houston
and he thought
that a man of his stature and
magnificence should have had more notice
by the
media more time on television more space
in the washington post and so on and so
he was constantly
seeking
uh means of his own self-aggrandizement
and he hit upon having a private
entrance made for himself at the
department of commerce on the other side
of the building from the
comp from the entrance in which the
the mere populace was to come and go and
he and he had the entrance built at
great expense
with a long awning
sort of like a canopy in front of a
nightclub or a restaurant
and i think he wanted to have it read
because
jim baker's canopy at the state
department was blue or he wanted it blue
because jim baker's canopy was red i
can't remember which way it went
but there were only six people allowed
to use that entrance it was mossbacker
himself
his wife
his secretary his deputy his lawyer for
all i know is valid
and then after he'd gotten that all
together
it still wasn't quite grand enough he
practiced walking in and out of the
uh that entrance for a number of weeks
and then he decided that still
that just once he got inside the
building there was a distance to go
to his own private elevator
but
between the entrance and the elevator
there were offices sort of cubicles in
which
the
poor people were
short sleeves i mean it was an unseemly
uh
display of uh
manual labor so he had the entire
inside of the
department of commerce that part of it
anyway reconstructed the offices were
moved
so that there was a
properly
open grand space between the entrance
and the elevator and i believe that
there was a table put there with a
simply a decoration of flowers
but it's that kind of uh
attitude that
too often uh
captures people i mean not only of
course in washington but elsewhere in
the in
within any
organization large enough to sustain its
own
theory of reality nancy reagan the color
red and a bed
she used to have her own bed uh or a
replica when she traveled with the
president
she would have a her own
bed or one exactly like it carried
a few days before she was
going to arrive in some foreign capital
and she also
was unless you
probably well remember she the color red
was a passion of hers
so that the rooms in which she was to
stay whether she was going to a palace
in
venice or a
castle in france or a hotel in
hawaii the rooms the room was painted
red
prior to her arrival and her bed was
placed the room was painted and then the
mirrors were all dropped
because nancy reagan was was fairly
short
and
sometimes the mirrors had to be brought
down to a level that didn't so she saw
more than the top of her head which
would otherwise
put her in bad mood for the afternoon
jack kent cook who owns the washington
redskins you quote him saying i'm a
republican but strangely i have a great
many democratic friends
dodd brzezinski greenspan he's of
indeterminate lineage sam donaldson
what's he jane mccarthy and george
mcgovern what's the point here the point
is that jack kent cook is the owner of
the washington redskins and that one of
the
most
valued places at court in washington is
in
jack kent cook's box at
jfk rfk stadium
and it's a large box i believe there are
50 or 60 places in it and of course
during the
uh long period of a republican
administration the box was filled with
important republicans and shortly after
the election of clinton i believe within
two days
suddenly it turned out
cook discovered all of his democratic
friends and the
their
seats were changed and
with a new administration
the court brings in new
courtiers and cook who's very quick to
to see that it's
it's the constant game in washington as
you know
far better than i who's in who's out i
mean who
who will come who will go who will get
to
write the senator's speeches or carry
the general shirt or or
sit in jack kent cook's box or have a
parking space at the national airport i
mean these are
questions of
vast weight
you also quote mr cook is saying the box
is not used to ingratiate myself with
the administration please quote me this
is the new york times actual quote
please quote me precise on that i invite
people who are good company happy
cheerful good humored people who love
football
it's a great statement i'm it's
worthy of a politician but i mean it's
i'm sure you can all people who are in
jack kent cook's box are apt to be
happy and cheerful and loving football
almost
of necessity i mean that that would be
whether they're democrats or republicans
you write about the world bank and first
class versus business class travel
what's the world bank world bank is
a large
lending institution which
arranges loans
usually for underdeveloped countries
loans for economic assistance
and it takes
most of the funds come from the united
states and the headquarters world banker
here in washington but it does assemble
funds from other countries in the world
and so its mission is to the
the poorer
uh more hard-pressed
countries of the earth
but it it sustains a a fairly sizable
bureaucracy of its own very
comfortable one very highly paid people
and
one of these people on one of his
jaunts to
some desolate
heath in africa had figured out that if
he traveled business class instead of
first class he would save a great deal
of money
and
he then worked out the equation that
if this practice was
adopted by other members of the
hierarchy of the world bank they would
they would save 12 million dollars a
year and this is not too great a
decline in accommodation i mean we're
simply going from first class to
business class and saving 12 million
dollars
but when this memorandum was passed
around within the
corridors at the world bank it
evoked feelings of
horror disbelief dismay and
one of the vice presidents uh
uh sent back a counter memo saying if
i can't remember the exact words but it
was the effect that uh
this couldn't you know this sort of
suggestion was uh outrageous and that uh
if mr whoever it was didn't have more
concern for the
comfort of his
colleagues he should be dismissed at
once and return you know sent to some
dark place of exile but it was the the
feeling of
how can they
take this away from me
if a story in here about bob gray who is
he and what's his relationship to you
bob gray was a man i
began to
when i i first began i first came to
washington in the late 1950s during
the eisenhower administration
i'd come from university and i was
trying to decide what
kind of career to to follow what's cool
i'd gone to yale university in the in
the united states then i go to cambridge
university in england and the
so i came and i talked as a very young
man i i approached the cia i approached
the washington post and i also
approached the white house and i was
sent to talk to
mr gray great at this point in time
eventually became an enormously
successful
uh lobbyist and uh trafficker and
influence and and patronage
and now as i believe he had his own
lobbying firm for many years and is now
with hillary knowlton
but then he was a young man and he was
an aide to eisenhower
and i can remember being interviewed by
him uh he had very little time he was he
was
hard-pressed and we the interview took
place in the
basement of the white house
in the in the barber shop i mean there
was a garbage chair down
there in those days
and
the only other place for me to sit was
on the toilet i sat on the toilet and
gray sat in the in the barber chair and
i was at the level of his
shoes which i remember being very
beautiful shoes
and he
i started to talk about democratic
theory i was very young very idealistic
and
gray waved that all off and sort of said
to don't
please don't
waste anybody's time he said the whole
thing about
government
about washington or about power is is
simply to acquire the right sort of
friends and
make connections and
do what you're told
until the great day comes when you can
tell others what to do
carry whatever
water
must be carried and so on it was a very
realistic assessment
and uh
a very uh clear
uh statement of the principle which i
never forgot i mean he made it very
articulately what happened to bob gray
after 1957.
he became after i he then went into his
i set up his own firm and became uh
very influential in
in a number of as a lobbyist as a man
who makes introductions who
arranges things who
helps
legislation
um
more easily through the
channels of the congress and so on
lobbyist i believe is the term what
happened to you
not me i i went
into the newspaper business i became a
newspaper reporter first for the san
francisco examiner
and then for the
new york herald tribune
and then i became a magazine writer in
the most of the 60s for the saturday
being posted for life
magazine and then what
then i became
a writer for harper's magazine in
about 1970 and then in 1971
i became by default uh a managing editor
because there was a uh
one of those office politics things that
happens in new york magazine offices
fairly frequently
so
the then editor
resigned so did some of the other
editors i didn't agree with their
unhappiness
so i stayed and i became on on a monday
i was a writer and on tuesday i became a
managing editor and i remained
i was the managing editor for four years
and then i became the editor in 1976
how long did you stay there
well i was the editor for about uh let's
see from 1976 to 1981 then i was fired
and uh
spent two years in exile uh
and rehired in 1989
yeah 1993 i was then
the glorious return i was i was recalled
as the editor of the magazine so i've
been the editor twice
once 1976-81 and again from 83 until now
you dedicate this book to john r
mcarthur who is wary of merchants let
alone kings who is john r mcarthur john
r macarthur is the publisher of harper's
magazine and
is a
related to the
large
macarthur family
well-known
family in chicago
and he became associated with harper's
magazine
very early when it in 1980 became
interested in the
in the magazine and
it's a long story but
when the magazine went bankrupt in 1980
it was through his influence that the
magazine was rescued first by the john r
macarthur foundation
and then
in turn by the harpers magazine
foundation
he is
first of all a journalist and has
himself
written
a good book called the
second front which he published last
year which is a book about the press
coverage of of the uh gulf war
and then he's also the publisher of the
magazine but he's a very um
very good person for me to work for
because he
encourages
freedom of expression i mean he's not
nervous about
offending the powers to be where's the
macarthur money come from originally
originally comes from john r macarthur
his grandfather
who was
a man who made a great fortune in the
real estate and in insurance businesses
and began
to acquire his fortune in the in the
depression in the early 1930s
in the middle of that period when you
were without a job yeah
you had a dinner with
that you were invited to that just
guarded standing the former
president of france to tell that story
well
i was again this is i'm trying to
explain that the courtier spirit the
attitude of
um
bowing and scraping that takes place in
various uh
large american institutions is true of
certainly in washington but it's also
true of
quite a few business corporations it's
true within the media it's true in the
universities to find the word court here
courtier is one who uh
says
to a succession of masters
make of me
what you want i am what you want me to
be
in other words it's an
a toady
a
dependent
somebody willing to
do whatever is asked by
his or her boss and
lives
by making a constantly gracious
impression it's a
yes man would be another way of uh
that'll be another phrase for it
anyway
the
in
1981 i was the editor of the magazine
and i had been
um
asked to a very small dinner for at the
council on foreign relations in new york
for jisgardestan
and
i was invited i believe on the 1st of
august and then i was fired on the 15th
of august
and
the dinner was on the 15th of september
and a few days before the dinner i the
council called me up and
wanted to know
what title should go after my name on
the little
piece of paper that's distributed to
everybody at the dinner
and i of course by that time had none
gone it's this long and ghastly silence
and i i meant i've finally managed to
resolve it by saying that i wrote an
occasional
article for the washington post and so
they were
i didn't have any
permanent employment with the post but
it was enough to get on the piece of
paper would they have invited you if
you didn't have a job
it wouldn't have been
probably not no i mean the
again the notion of the court the notion
of titles the notion of
one is known by
one's institutional affiliation
the plain
democratic name
it has to have the
of
mobile oil corporation of the new york
times of c-span of harper's magazine of
whatever i mean it's the
we as americans like to pride ourselves
uh
as individualists
constantly and one of the images of
ourselves that we like the best is that
of the
clint eastwood figure for the
man against the system the
cowboy
fearing west and the rain
but we in fact are people that are
very much
dependent upon our institutional
identities and
identifications i am of the bank i am of
the paper i am of the studio whatever
and this of course is one of the
premises of theses of the book which is
as the
courtier spirit
which is the accommodating spirit
the democratic spirit is the one that
that simply speaks out and says whatever
it's in its mind
and candor is one of the great
democratic political virtues
the
we're democrats to the extent that we
try to tell each other
what we know what we've seen what we
feel
we're courtiers to the extent that we
tell each other
what we each of us want to hear
and
so that that
the book
is is saying that as more and more
people in this country become more and
more dependent on large
institutions whereas
in the last part of the 19th century
most americans were self-employed
something like 80 percent of the
population many of them farmers
obviously but
farmers and small
craftsmen and businessmen
as the
in the 20th century as the large
institutional organizations
come forward
now i think only two percent of the
american people are are self-employed
and if you if one depends on
an
institution for
for one's whole existence i mean not
only medical insurance but also close
allowance also pension also placed in
the world also business card and so
forth
then the independent habit of mind tends
to give way
to the
more accommodating habit of mind that's
the one of the arguments note 6 in the
back of the book the story of
kissinger's life is the story of the
perfect courtier
kissinger was a man who knew how to play
the court world uh
extremely well i mean
he began as a
um
he was discovered by nelson rockefeller
when he'd been a kissinger started as an
academic he was at harvard
history professor i believe
and then somehow he managed to get to
nelson rockefeller and and he provided
nelson rockefeller with whatever
theories nelson rock posted governor of
new york and had presidential ambitions
and he provided him with
theories of the cold war theories of
nuclear disarmament theories of nuclear
exchange i forget
in what succession they they came but
but
kissinger again was a man always willing
to
[Music]
arrange the world to fit the desire of
his
patron
whether it was
rockefeller or nixon or
sometimes
important senior columnists in the media
i mean he understood that it was that
the world of
was a world of poses of
the right word at the right time whether
the theory actually was true or not
whether it had any relation to the facts
or not was less important than the way
it
advanced or
failed to advance kissinger's career
it's a little bit off the subject but
it's in your book and it's note number
12. you talk about an advertising
executive
who had to give an enema
to a client a client once a month once a
week what in the world is that story
that story is i'm saying that as the
well it's a story about uh
um
trying to put it down there's new
information by the way in this book no
is this this your this first time it's
been published this little story yeah i
mean
you found this out a fellow explained
this to me yeah well tell the whole
story if you don't mind well it's the
story i mean the magazine business again
as um
people become more independent on their
patrons more willing to do what is ever
necessary to do
to get the vote or to
get the
part or to get the account
people who are in the position of
granting those
requests
begin to have more and more
refined
desires and appetites i mean it's a
variation on the whole story about the
hollywood producer who insists that the
young
aspiring actress go to bed with him
before she can get the part
in this instance it's the story of a ad
salesman who is
uh
dependent on a client for a very large
account a couple of hundred thousand
dollars a year
in business for the
magazines in question and
the client had a
weird
sexual
request which
required the advertising fellow to show
up i think once every two months in a
motel and uh
somewhere in new jersey and and
administer an enemy to the gentleman so
and by the way you say you had to wear a
seersucker suit a bow tie either yellow
or pink yeah there were certain
sartorial requirements
but it's an example of the happens to be
a fairly
unhappy example or dismal example but
there are many many examples like that
throughout the society people that are
in power that have power over
their
dependents this essentially was the
argument between
clarence thomas and anita hill it wasn't
it was the argument about what does the
individual in authority what can he
insist upon
on the part of his subordinates you have
a letter in here i'll read just a little
bit of it dear mr president
here with the first run off the press of
a book called the making of the
president 1968
whose hero is richard m nixon
later on you say
this gentleman says the campaign that
this book tries to describe was the
campaign of a man of courage and of
conscience
and the respect
it rung for me which i hope is evident
surprised me week by week as i went
along
later this man writes there's no there's
so much difference between being a
reporter and being a citizen and his
last line and this president can also
call on me as a friend
sincerely teddy white right why did you
put that in this book i put that in
because it i'm trying to show the
relation of the um
the
media the the press to power which is
again the relation of the courtier
trying to
curry favor among the
people
whom it
it describes to stay friends i mean in
that particular book
white had some rather sharp things to
say about nixon but the
he he wanted to maintain his
place in court i
i believe this is true i don't know if
this is in the book but i've been told
and i i think it's true is that that kay
graham in the washington post
shortly after
nixon was impeached i mean the same
month sent him a nice note and said
don't worry when it's all over we'll
we'll have dinner i mean it's um
it's that relation
the relation is always to power
and if you're out of power
nobody can remember your name and if
you're
in power
everybody's your best friend the the
case of nixon's career is a
brilliant
uh demonstration of that i mean a man
who was considered a used car salesman
impeached and now he's
20 years ago his name was synonymous
with scoundrel crook and now his name is
synonymous with
statesman and
philosopher
the last line of the jacket on your book
says the several facets of this question
come into brilliant focus in this
important book by one of our most
incisive social critics
no one who cares about the future of our
nation should miss reading the wish for
kings they're writing about you
and the only reason i bring that up is
that you then have a note in here that
says the talent for self-promotion is by
no means unique to washington in new
york it is common practice for authors
to write the jacket copy for their own
books that's true did you write the
jacket copy for your own book i don't
think so i certainly edited it i mean
what happens is that the uh the
publisher writes it and then they submit
it to the to the author
and um
so i'm sure i had a hand in that
did you worry about the fact that you
had had a hand in that and then use this
footnote because you're right you're
critical of a guy named gordon lish
who wrote the following about himself
there is no other contemporary figure in
the nation's literary community whose
presence is as widely or as urgently
felt
i don't think i think it's a question of
degree i mean it's a question i thought
the lish
was a little over the top i thought the
words that the publisher used on my own
behalf were
fairly cliched and familiar what about
this book um
it's published by um
grove uh harper's grow by grove press is
that owned by harper's no it's owned by
the atlantic monthly its own
there's something called the atlantic
monthly press
which
and then there was something called
grove press and just about the same time
that this book uh was published last
this spring
harper's i mean sorry atlantic monthly
press acquired grove press so now
they're a joint
publishing company
why did you want to write this book
i wanted to write the book because i was
trying to describe
what i saw not only in
i was trying to
report accurately
the
circumstance of the
when i kept encountering i mean and
again it's not only about government
it's about universities it's about
corporations about the media
and
and i don't exempt myself from the
conditions that i described but
people constantly go around and say
the american democracy is in trouble or
the united states is in decline and so
forth and it seems to me that if there's
any
that may be true but
one of the reasons that true
is true is there is an absence of of
democrats small d
i mean
something is evolving in this country
and has been over the last 20 years
away from the notion of of
democratic self-government and
even more to the point
a loss of faith in the democratic idea i
mean
freedom is good
but it's not enough
self-government would be wonderful if we
had the time
and the energy and the resources to
practice it
but in the meantime
give us somebody who will take care of
us
that's the wish for kings the wish for
kings is a very old wish it's the
it's the wish that brings in caesar it's
the wish that brings in the men on the
white horse the magical figure that will
uh
resolve all one's
troubles
and it is
antithetical to the uh democratic notion
of
discovering one's own future you right i
have come across only a small number of
people who can talk about any particular
book at convincing length
that is true in in in new york uh new
york is uh that's a remark i believe
about the new york literary
world
where
the conversation is much more apt to be
about
the author's
standing in the market i mean everybody
has read the reviews
and everybody knows
whether the book is up or down or in or
out
and everybody has something
to say about it
in a couple of sentences
but i find at least within the
court world of the new york literary
scene that relatively few people have
had the time to read all the way through
the uh
through the book i i find that when i
travel around the country
that if i'm in
california or if i'm in
ohio or texas and i run across somebody
who's read the book they're apt to have
read the whole thing and are prepared to
really talk about it whereas in new york
i get the
the current opinion
you had a book show on television i did
what was the name of it it was called
bookmark
and it appeared it was on public
broadcasting and it was on for three
years
1989 1991 i believe what was the format
very similar to this one except
it went for half an hour we take a book
just just the way we're doing now
and
i would play your part and you would
play mine and then
often i would have one or two other
people
in the conversation
usually writers
who had thought about or had written
about the subject under
of the who could add to the conversation
and
either argue with the writer or
provide a
different perspective and the the object
was to try to get a
conversation about ideas going in in a
half an hour
if you still had the show and you were
playing my role and you had somebody
else sitting at the table for this book
what kind of person would you invite
well
you'd have to
i might ask somebody like
hedrick smith hendrik smith wrote a book
called the power game
and published a very
interesting book came out i think
four years ago and he
well-known figure in washington this
would be
certainly from the washington side
this would be a very familiar
topic to him and he would
agree with some of it and argue with
some of it but again he's very
good
on television i mean he would have been
a
an interesting presence what happened to
the show
the show
lost its funding i mean it was supported
by the
bell atlantic telephone company
and
they supported that company for three
years and then
the people who had been responsible for
that
within bell atlantic
went to other companies
the new people in the
bell atlantic had no interest in it and
i i couldn't raise money for it i i
tried it was at that point was running
in 147 stations
um
it was beginning to
evolve and was beginning to acquire an
audience
and uh but i i went to various
corporations i went to
some foundations but i never could i
never could um
find the
the money to to put it back on what'd
you think of public television
and how does that fit in the your you
know the because i know you write
something about it in the wish for king
yeah i think public television in my
experience of it was very much part of
the the court world in other words there
um they had certain
people i
came up against had certain set
attitudes i mean i brought the book show
first to the station in washington and
i was simply told that
we here at
the station we're not interested in
books
we never want to hear more than
uh three minutes a day of a book review
on
npr and
we appreciate your
concern but no
and this was even with the funding
presented to them i mean i went to that
meeting with the people from bell
atlantic
and then we encountered the same thing
when we tried to put the show on through
philadelphia
and new york
was willing to take the show but only if
we
dressed it up with production values so
i encountered
hostility to
to books to ideas on
on the part of pbs i mean
this kind of show would be considered
talking heads and uh
therefore
not interested not good for ratings not
show business and i
encountered that attitude
almost wherever i went within
pbs
i think they're wrong because i happen
to like talking heads the
i think they're interesting but
and i also think that the public
broadcasting system should try to do
more of this kind of thing
because as you know
there are a lot of interesting people in
the country and and they have a lot of
interesting things to say and they don't
not enough of them appear
either on
certainly not on the networks and and
not enough on the public broadcasting
system i've underlined a couple of other
comments you may hear about some
individuals i just want to read them and
get your reaction as to why you said
that
the television and publishing media
award
i'm reading this wrong the television
and publishing media award alan
dershowitz the reputation of an
incomparable trial lawyer
in homage to his talent for publicity
rather than in recognition of his record
in appeals cases which as of the summer
of 1992 stood at nine wins and 39 losses
yes the the
tendency again is to go for the
reputation dershowitz is a great
self-promoter
he has won some spectacular cases but he
has lost
more than he has won
but
people like i believe
leona helmsley and then
mike tyson both were persuaded by his
reputation
and
both of them went more or less directly
to jail as i remember i mean he didn't
triumph in their
cases
but
again the
media image the reputation
often
is a surrogate for
the work itself i mean again take
kissinger and take nixon both of them
have
still reputations as
prescient statesmen people who were
clear-eyed and
and saw the
the shape of the world and yet if you
look back on their
their record
it's
like dershowitz's record i mean they
were wrong on
vietnam they didn't understand the
oil crisis of the early 70s
they certainly didn't understand iran
or the shah
they didn't foresee
the change in russia
neither of them ever understood the
economy they didn't understand what it
would mean to go off
uh to change the
gold standard
in the
early 70s
so that
the
the
the record is is based on
uh to a large extent on on
image
and very little on on substance
elizabeth taylor
but the media chatter incessantly about
the people for whom the society has the
least use about elizabeth taylor's
wedding or jay leno's contract or maria
shriver's hair
and they uh let me return the page and
they take little notice of people or
professions on whom the society utterly
depends
how come
the
former figures the celebrity figures
tend to be more um
fun
i mean they're you know they can be
brilliantly illuminated they're
they provide gossip
they're decorative i mean the
to keep
celebrities in a way is like
keeping pets i mean they're they're
expensive
but they
they
they relieve people of their
own
um grief for their own concerns they can
it's it's like a great
puppet show that takes place or it's
like a pageant at court
to get back to that image
it's like a masked ball and these people
are
uh
more fun to talk about and and
and the
again with the wonders of the modern
technology with it with the television
people throughout the country identify
with them i mean the the stars of
afternoon television soap opera shows
receive a hundred thousand letters a
week from
fans
telling them things that the
correspondents would never tell their
fathers
wives husbands you know i mean
confessional
you uh you write about a dinner party
you were in attendance
and you're sitting next to a lady you're
talking about democracy
before i ask you about that let me read
this statement you write over the course
of the last 20 years and across the span
of an extensive acquaintance among the
people who enjoy most of the country's
advantages
bond salesmen and politicians as well as
publishers corporate vice presidents
novelist lawyers english professors and
under secretaries of state i have
noticed that most of the respondents
fear
and despise both the theory and the
practice of democracy
i think that's true i'm talking about
it's the thing i said earlier when i
said that if if you asked me why did i
write this book
the answer is that
i've encountered
if you ask me what is the trouble with
with the american democracy i will say
to you the absence of democrats in small
d
they despise it though
i think they fear it maybe
in certain people despise it i mean they
the the attitude of the uh
um
the attitude
the despising takes takes the form of uh
the superior judgment and taste let's
say
of either
new york or
washington we happy few we here in new
york
understand it
but they on the other side of the
allegheny mountains won't understand it
or we happy few here in washington
know what is meant by but they won't
know what is meant by the scent
sorry what about that lady i mean that
the lady at the party kind of
uh dovetails with what you just said
yes i i'm not sure which lady she's the
one that
i found myself wondering how it is
possible to preserve the democratic
spirit in a society distinguished by the
absence of democrats at a dinner in
washington in february i would seat it
next to a woman who thought the
democracy was supposed to be easy quiet
orderly peaceful and safe right that's
true
by the way you didn't name some of these
people they're going to know who they
are when they reach out i would think so
you're going to be invited back to these
dinners do you think
i have no idea
maybe maybe
the uh
but again
that woman's sort of thought in terms of
democracy as as a fourth of july parade
not as a
ceaseless argument and again the
attitude toward
please no confrontation democracy is
about confrontation it's about you and i
disagreeing with each other it's about
it's not easy it's not orderly it's not
especially safe
and
the language of the court the language
of people who despise the vulgarity of
two
sharp
an opinion or too
garish
a taste
say
don't want to argue
you know this woman you know was amazed
to discover that uh
that individual property rights could
sometimes actually be in conflict with
community rights i mean this came to her
as the great
news
and when i say despise and when i say a
few democrats then you have to look at
the instinct all over the country to
sort of withdraw into
enclaves take the city of los angeles
where you have the people in
bel air or in pasadena or in beverly
hills living behind
safe perimeters behind walls behind
their own police forces just trying to
divorce and distance themselves from
the
proletarians wandering in the streets
now that's happening all across the
country the whole advertising business
is based on the point
of making class distinctions
in the timer i think one of the things
is you dish it out to just about
everybody in here uh on both sides and i
want to make sure i get the balance uh
you say bill clinton
cast himself as a friend of the american
victim
the promises he made in the name of a
custodial state could easily have been
confused with a program of diet and
exercise for a generation of lost
children and abbreviated a list of his
promises reads as follows and you go
through all of his promises and earlier
you said the philosophers of the liberal
left several of whom composed governor
clinton's thesis of economic deliverance
believe that although money is wicked in
the hands of mere individuals it regains
its blessedness in the hands of the
state
yes
that's the
both believe both left and right believe
that money is
wonderful if only properly used i mean
the
conservatives have to think that
it's best left to the individual with no
government
regulation or rules and the the statist
the person who says uh
the government knows best
and therefore if we spend the money on
behalf of others it's it's it's a
different uh
use but it's
in in either instance money is
blessed only in the hands of those
in the hands of the right people however
they happen to be defined
is there any way to define your own
politics at this stage in your life
after reading this book
did you conclude anything i conclude
that i mean writing this book excuse me
well i conclude that i
i want to get on i want to try to learn
how to
describe the circumstances of the
american democracy at this point in time
in in a language that's more accurate
than the one we've been using i mean one
of our difficulties this country is we
don't have a vocabulary yet
in which we can
accurately
tell each other
what we want i mean how do you solve
what are the words to solve let's say
the health care crisis there is no
solution until we can come to
a prior agreement as to what
we expect
i mean otherwise the desire for
immortality i mean we now spend 600
billion a year or seven percent of our
gnp
and that will just continue i mean we
will bankrupt ourselves and let because
we will the desire to stay
immortal
i mean how are you going to
how are we going to control
that um
desire that urge unless we come to some
prior
agreement as to what we're about
are you a liberal or a conservative
well i would say i was culturally a
conservative but i tend to be
politically a liberal i mean i'm i have
elements of both in them you have a
favorite president
you mean other than lincoln and
jefferson
okay
they would be my they're the ones i i
probably know what do you think of the
kennedy legacy
i think it was
again it's part of the wish for kings
it's the
i think there was less there than we
wish
there would be
lyndon johnson
johnson to me was a fascinating figure i
actually met johnson i worked in the
white house as a in the white house
you know press corps during his briefly
while he was president
and i've read quite a lot of
books about johnson and and
it's a i don't have a simple answer i
mean the elements are so mixed in
johnson that that i think he's uh
in some ways almost a tragic figure
jimmy carter
carter i think is a much better as an
ex-president than he is as a
as he was as a president and
i misread carter at the time i think i
the more i know about carter the more
um impressed i am with him ross perot
perrault i think is a autocrat i mean i
read him that way i see him as a
man who if he could run he's very
um
he knows what's wrong
but the way he wants to fix it to me is
very unclear
and i i get the uneasy feeling with
perot that if if um
that he would like the country to be run
either
you know
either as a prisoner or as a monastery i
mean he would be the abbot or the warden
and i i don't think he's a very
i don't think he has much sense of
democratic debate
reagan taught the country that it wasn't
necessary for a president to know
anything about law or foreign policy or
free speech or trees or black people or
whales government was a salesman smile
and a gift for phrase
a phrase i think that's true reagan i
think
reagan was shrewder than many people
thought but i also think he was
primarily an actor
he was a man who read a script
and
what the words meant
i often think
he didn't know nor did he think it
wasn't why don't star wars would be a
wonderful example i mean he was on his
way to a budget meeting the first budget
conference the summit
and
the night before jim baker was on the
secretary of the treasury he had given
him a briefing book
and uh they get in the limousine to go
to the summit the next day and
baker says to reagan well did you have a
chance to read the briefing book and
reagan looked at him in horror
and said what jim
the sound of music was on last night
i mean
of course he didn't have time to read it
he i don't think he had time
i don't think he had
to be especially well informed on those
uh
various heads
where were you born san francisco
how long did you live there
i lived there uh until i was about uh
13 years old
and then my
parents moved to new york and i came to
new york and went to school
boarding school and then to college in
connecticut what professions were your
parents
about
my father my father had been in
first in the shipping business and then
in the
banking business
what impact did cambridge have on you
well cambridge showed me
uh
the difference between an american
university education and english
university education i also
uh formed in a
i learned to admire
c.s lewis who was then
at cambridge and e.m forster was then at
cambridge and so i i was
allowed into the presence of
men whom i thought
exemplary in many ways
were you concerned when you wrote this
book that you were stepping on a lot of
toes and that you might not be welcome
in some places that you used to go to
no because i've
the people who've
writing a column a monthly column for
harper's magazine for a number of years
i've
i've already stepped on quite a few toes
so that i'm
i don't expect any new doors will be be
closed if there's there been any
reaction different reaction to this book
say than that magazine i mean the people
buying this book that don't normally buy
harpers
i think so i think so i'm beginning to
get letters from people that i that who
don't aren't familiar with what i've
written and it's very encouraging how's
it selling
i think it's selling quite well
what's that mean to you what what all
that means is with my publicist tells me
that the publisher tells me that it's
it's doing well
and that i don't know what that means
but
presumably
and i also know that people go and
ask for it in bookstores and it's
already been
sold out and they've had to order
another 20 copies what's the
circulation of harper's 210 000 is it
making money
no
uh harper's last year had its best year
and uh
since 1962 we only lost 67 dollars how
long are you going to keep it up
well i think we it is we could keep up
that loss for quite a long time how
about you how long are you gonna
stay the editor as long as i can uh
get up in the morning and think that
it's fun to go down to the
go down to work next book
next book is about yale university
when
published the fall of 1995.
our guest has been lewis laplame is the
editor of harper's and this is what the
book looks like the wishes for kings
democracy at bay thank you very much
thank you brian
[Music]
next week on book notes we'll discuss
the political debates between abraham
lincoln and stephen douglas
the series of seven debates which began
on august 21st 1858 are chronicled by
civil war historian harold holzer in the
recent book the lincoln douglas debates
that's next sunday on book notes at 8
and 11 pm
eastern time
coming next on c-span a look at politics
in great britain
[Music]
for a transcript of this edition of book
notes please send five dollars to c-span
transcripts in care of tape writer
incorporated post office box 885 in
lincolnshire illinois the zip code is
six zero zero six nine
members of the united states